hello everybody good morning i'm tom
shirk president of the academy thank you
thank you we've got some news to break
this morning but before we do please
welcome the very talented actress and an
Oscar nominee herself last year and
Hathaway thank you Tom good morning
everyone the 2009 nominees for Best
Performance by an actress in a
supporting role are Penelope Cruz in
nine Vera fer Maga it up in the air
Maggie Gyllenhaal in Crazy Heart Anna
Kendrick in up in the air and Monique in
precious yeah thank you
for Best Performance by an actor in a
supporting role the nominees are Matt
Damon in Invictus Woody Harrelson in the
messenger Christopher Plummer in the
last station Stanley Tucci in The Lovely
Bones and Christoph Waltz in Inglourious
Basterds for Best Performance by an
actress in a leading role the nominees
are Sandra Bullock in The Blind Side
Helen Mirren in the last station Carey
Mulligan in and education Gabourey
Sidibe in precious and Meryl Streep in
Julie and Julia the nominees for Best
Performance by an actor and the leading
role are Jeff Bridges in Crazy Heart
George Clooney and up in the air Colin
Firth in a single man Morgan Freeman in
Invictus
and jeremy renner in The Hurt Locker
that's good the best achievement in
directing James Cameron for avatar
Kathryn Bigelow for The Hurt Locker
Quentin Tarantino for Inglourious
Basterds Lee Daniels for precious and
Jason Reitman for up in the air thank
you for Best Original Screenplay the
nominees are Mark Boal for The Hurt
Locker Quentin Tarantino for Inglourious
Basterds Alessandro kamon and Oren Moe
vermin for the messenger Joel Coen and
Ethan Coen for a serious man
and Pete docter Bob Peterson and Tom
McCarthy for up for adapted screenplay
we have Neill Blomkamp and Terri
Tatchell for district 9 Nick Hornby for
an education Jesse Armstrong Simon
Blackwell Armando Iannucci and Tony
Roche for in the loop Jeffrey Fletcher
for precious and Jason Reitman and
Sheldon Turner for up in the air for
Best Foreign Language Film we have from
Israel ajami from Argentina el secreto
de sus ojos from Peru the milk of sorrow
from France
uncle FET and from Germany the white
ribbon for Best Animated Feature the
nominees are Coraline Henry Selick
fantastic mr. Fox Wes Anderson The
Princess and the Frog John Musker and
Ron Clements The Secret of Kells Tom
Moore and up Pete docter
and finally I'm pleased to announce that
the ten film selected as Best Picture
nominees for two
thousand nine our avatar James Cameron
and John Landau producers the blindside
nominees to be determined district nine
Peter Jackson and Carolyn Cunningham
producers an education Finola Dwyer and
Amanda Posey producers The Hurt Locker
nominees to be determined inglourious
basterds Lawrence bender producer
precious lee daniels sarah siegel magnus
and gary magnus producers a serious man
joel coen and Ethan Coen producers up
Jonas Rivera producer and up in the air
Daniel do biacky Ivan Reitman and Jason
Reitman producers please join us in a
little more than a month on Sunday March
7th when we find out who goes home with
the Oscar it will be a night to remember
see you then